what is beauty anyway
it would be nice to just try to discuss
what kind of thing we would like to
converge towards
in our
understanding of what is beautiful
so to me i think something is beautiful
when
it can't be reduced down to
easy metrics like if you think of a tree
what is it about a tree like a big
ancient beautiful tree right what is it
about it that we find so beautiful it's
not you know the
the you know what the sweetness of its
fruit
or the value of its lumber
it's
it's this entirety of it
that is that there's these immeasurable
qualities it's like almost like a qualia
of it
um
that's both like it walks this fine line
between pattern well it's got lots of
patternicity but it's not overly
predictable
um you know again it walks this fine
line between order and chaos it's a very
highly complex system
um in the
you know you can't it's evolving over
time you know the definition of a
complex versus and this is another
schmackenberger thing you know a complex
versus a complicated system a
complicated system can be sort of broken
down into bits understood and then put
back together a complex system it's kind
of like a black box it does all this
crazy stuff
but if you take it apart you can't put
it back together again because it's
there's there's all these intricacies
and also very importantly like there's
some of the parts sorry the sum of the
whole is much greater than the sum of
the parts and that's where the beauty
lies i think and i think that extends to
things like art as well like
there's something there's something
immeasurable about it there's something
we can't break down to a narrow metric
does that extend to humans you think
yeah
absolutely
so how can instagram reveal that kind of
beauty the complexity of a human being
good question
um this takes us back to our dating
sites and good reads i think
very good question i mean
well i know what it shouldn't do it
shouldn't try and like right now
you know one of the most i was talking
to like a social media expert recently
because i was like
ugh i hate things the social media
expert oh yeah you there are like
agencies out there that you can like
outsource because i'm thinking about
working with one to like
i said i want to start a podcast yeah
you should you should have done it a
long time ago working on it it's going
to be called win-win um and it's going
to be about this like positive some
stuff uh and
the thing that you know they they always
come back and say it's like well you
need to like figure out what your thing
is you know you need to narrow down what
your thing is and then just follow that
have a like a sort of a formula
because that's what people want they
want to know that they're coming back to
the same thing and that's the advice on
youtube twitter you name it and that's
why and and the trouble with that is
that it's a complexity reduction and
generally speaking complex you know
complexity reduction is bad it's making
things more it's an oversimplification
not that simplification is always a bad
thing um
but when you're trying to
in
take you know what is social media doing
it's trying to like encapsulate the the
human experience and put it into digital
form and and commodify it to an extent
that you so you do that you compress
people down into these like narrow
things
and that that's why i think it's it's
kind of ultimately fundamentally
incompatible with at least my definition
of beauty it's interesting because
there is some sense in which
a simplification sort of in the in the
einstein kind of sense
of a really complex idea
a simplification in a way that still
captures some core
power of an idea of a person
is also beautiful
and so maybe it's possible for social
media to do that a presentation
a sort of a slither a sl a slice a look
into a person's life
that reveals something real about them
but in a simple way in a way that can be
displayed graphically or through words
some way i mean
in some way twitter can do that kind of
thing a very few set of words can reveal
the intricacies of a person
of course
the the viral machine that spreads those
words
uh often
results in people taking the thing out
of context not
it the people often don't read tweets in
the context of the human being that
wrote them the full the full history of
the tweets they've written the education
level the humor level the
the world view they're playing around
with
all that context is forgotten and people
just see the different words so that can
lead to trouble but in in a certain
sense if you do take it in context
it reveals some kind of quirky little
beautiful idea or a profound little idea
from that particular person that shows
something about that person so in that
sense twitter can be more successful if
we talk about molex is driving a better
kind of incentive
yeah i mean how they can
like if
if we were to rewrite it is there a way
to rewrite the twitter algorithm so that
it stops being
the like
the fertile breeding ground of the
culture wars because that's really what
it is it's
um i mean
maybe i'm giving it you know twitter too
much power you know power but
just the more i looked into it and i had
a conversation with uh
tristan harris uh from centre of humane
technology and he explained it as like
twitter is where you have this amalgam
of human culture
and then this terribly designed
algorithm that amplifies the craziest
people um
and the the angriest the angriest most
uh divisive takes and amplifies them and
then the media the mainstream media
because all the journalists are also on
twitter they then
are informed by that and so they draw
out the stories they can from this
already like
very boiling lava of of
of
rage and then spread that
you know to their millions and millions
of people who aren't even on twitter um
and so i honestly i think if i could
press a button and turn them off i
probably would at this point because i
just don't see a way of being compatible
with healthiness but that's not gonna
happen um
and
so at least one way to like stem the
tide and make it less molecule would be
to
um
change
at least if like it was on a
subscription model then it's now not
optimizing for in you know
uh
impressions because basically what it
wants is for people to keep coming back
as often as possible that's how they get
paid right um every time an ad gets
shown to someone and the way is to get
people constantly refreshing their feed
so you're trying to encourage addictive
behaviors whereas if someone um
if they moved on to at least a
subscription model then
they're getting the money either way
whether someone comes back to the site
once a month or 500 times a month they
get the same amount of money so now that
takes away that incentive you know to
use technology you know to build to
design an algorithm that is maximally
addictive
um that would be one way for example
yeah but you still want people to
yeah i just feel like that just slows
down creates friction in the virality of
things but that's good
we need to slow down
good it's one way
variety is monolith
to be clear
so
malik is always negative then
yes
by definition yes
but then it disagrees it's not always
negative competition is neutral i
disagree with you that all virality is
negative then uh uh ismalik then
because
i i
it's a good intuition because we have a
lot of data on virality being negative
but i happen to believe that the core of
human beings so most human beings want
to be good
more than they want to be bad to each
other and so
i think it's possible it might be just
harder to engineer
systems that enable virality but it's
possible to engineer systems that are
viral
that enable virality and
the kind of stuff that rises to the top
is things that are positive and positive
not like
lala positive it's more like win-win
meaning a lot of people need to be
challenged wise things yeah you grow
from it it might challenge you you might
not like it but you ultimately grow from
it
and ultimately
bring people together as opposed to tear
them apart yeah i
deeply want that to be true and i very
much agree with you that people at their
core are on average good as opposed you
know care for each other as opposed to
not like a you know i think it's
actually a very small percentage of
people are truly like wanting to do just
like destructive malicious things most
people are just trying to win their own
little game and they don't mean to be
you know they're just stuck in this
badly designed system
um
that said the current structure yes is
the current structure
means that virality is optimized towards
molok that doesn't mean there aren't
exceptions you know sometimes positive
stories do go viral and i think we
should study them i think there should
be a whole field of study into
understanding
you know
identifying memes that
you know
above a certain threshold of the
population agree is a positive happy
bringing people together meme the kind
of thing that you know brings families
together that would normally argue about
cultural stuff at the table
at the dinner table um identify those
memes and figure out what it was what
was the ingredient that made them spread
that day um
and also like uh not just like
happiness and connection between humans
but
uh
connection between humans in other ways
that enables like productivity like
cooperation
solving difficult problems and all those
kinds of stuff uh you know so it's not
just about let's let's be happy and have
a fulfilling lives it's also like let's
build cool [ __ ] yeah
which is the spirit of collaboration
which is deeply anti-moloch right that's
that's uh it's not using competition
it's like
you know molech hates collaboration and
coordination and people working together
and that's you know again like the
internet started out as that and it and
um it could have been that but because
of the way it was sort of structured um
in terms of
uh you know
very lofty ideal they wanted everything
to be open source or open source and
also free
and but they needed to find a way to pay
the bills anyway because they were still
building this on top of our old economic
system um and so the way they did that
was through a third-party advertisement
but that meant that things were very
decoupled you know you've got this
third-party interest um which means that
you're then like people having to
optimize for that and that is
you know the actual consumer is actually
the product
not the not the
the the person you're making the thing
for you're in in the end you start
making the thing for the advertiser and
so that's why it then like breaks down
um
yeah like it's
there's no clean solution to this um
and i
it's a really good suggestion by you
actually to like
um
figure out how we can optimize virality
for
positive sum
topics i shall be the general of the
love bot army
um
strip you did
distributed distribution no okay yeah
the power just even in saying that the
power already went to my head
no okay
you